[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so first of all how many of you guys
have a coin bit account or any digital
currency account cool so a few so the
coin base is the easiest place to buy
and sell digital currency and our
mission is to create an open financial
system for the world so so far we've had
about 6 million people actually why
can't you see that ok yeah yep
so far we've helped about 6 million
people in 33 countries exchange about 6
billion in and all of digital currency
there's three districts eg support
Bitcoin ET diem and litecoin
and for the most part people are using
digital currency for some fascinating
applications right like cross-border
remittances it's it's faster it's
cheaper to use bitcoins to transfer
money from here to India from here to
Mexico etc and they're also you know use
cases like merchants can accept bitcoins
and sell goods where they're accepting
bitcoins without any charge back risk
because Bitcoin fundamentally if you
hold the private key you are the only
person who holds it and knows of it
right unless somebody with is ready to
actually export it out of you you know
you are the person who holds it all the
charge bags that happen in credit card
industry or banking they all happen
because you know none of them are able
to really verify that you are the true
owner of that bank account or the card
right but bitcoins it's a lot easier and
of course has an alternative investment
now the same reasons which make bitcoins
fascinating for you know all these
innovative use cases there are also the
same reasons which make bitcoins and
other digital currencies exciting for
you know the bad actors out there right
so the first reason being that bitcoin
is instant you can you know move money
instantly and it is non reversible so
you know if I were to send bitcoins to
someone I can't recover it back right
it's like cash so therefore you if I'm a
scammer that's the best thing I can
steal or buy right so if I have stolen a
hold of stolen credit cards or I have
stolen somebody's bank account
information you know that's a digital
currency exchange is the best ATM I can
go to right because I can steal money
from the credit card buy digital
currency and move it out instantly right
likewise
anyone who is storing this we can see at
coinbase they are prime targets because
you know like if you get into someone's
account then you can take the you can
run off with the district currency
instantly and no one can recover it
right which is why you know we like to
think of ourselves as a security company
first and a digital currency company
next right now I'm going to talk about
you know through the rest of the talk
these four topics so firstly I'll
motivate the payment for problems
secondly use a security problem and then
I will talk about you know how do we
detect and prevent fraud and finally I
will present a few interesting case
studies so first of all you know this is
the point based
signup flow you you know you give us you
email address you give us your phone
number then you connect a be your bank
account or you cut it card right and if
you connect your bank account then in
some cases we ask you to provide us with
the username and password for your bank
account in some cases you can verify
your bank account using micro deposits
right do you guys know if micro deposits
right so it's basically a few less than
a dollar value of deposits that will do
to you in to your bank and then you have
to come back and enter those micro
deposits back at coinbase right cool by
the way feel free to stop me interrupt
me any at any point so now what does
product coinbase look like so the
scammer
he feels a first person Alice's bank
account or credit card then to use a
second person Bob's identity drive a
license social security number third
Steve's a third person cars mobile phone
number as I said everybody who pays the
coinbase account has to have a mobile
phone number
right and you have to verify that you
have a position of that mobile phone
number and then you know bias
cryptocurrency and send it off of our
platform to a private wallet that only
the scammer controls now Alice finds out
you know while she's going through a
bank statement or credit card statement
that somebody did approaches using a
company called coinbase which she calls
up a bank or card company and disputes
the transaction and then the bank will
in turn you know start the dispute
mechanism with us and we would in a lot
of cases have to return the money back
to Alice the scammer ran off with the
bitcoins Alice gets some money back and
coinbase is left holding the bag right
so that's why when it comes to weather
water margins would be etcetera etcetera
fraud is you know one of the biggest
things that we have to keep in check not
a con takeover problem so as I was
describing earlier a user a you know
every user on coinbase has to have two
factors you know and the two factors
that they have to have a the first one
is something you know a strong password
and the second one is something you
always have in your position right
physical device so that's the
fundamentals behind the second factor
authentication if you have those two
factors that no one can actually get
into your account right unfortunately
this is not how to FA was implemented
right we said that phone number is
actually equivalent to the physical
device that is not true why because it
is actually relatively easy to steal
someone's phone number right
all those sms-based ufa tokens that you
get on your phone right I can get them
by redirecting your phone number to a
device I control or in other words
there's been a huge spurt it was a lot
of the last few months in you know phone
porting attacks right where an attacker
basically calls up you know the telco
provider the call center and claims that
hey I lost access to my iPhone or you
know I just bought a new iPhone can you
put my phone number to this new device
even if you have actually set up a pin
code on your account at any of the
telcos
the cameras are pretty crafty they are
able to actually get around it and they
can still convince via social
engineering the telco operator that yeah
you are who you are and then lo and
behold they have now your phone number
on their phone right so therefore they
can actually start getting SMS based to
a few tokens in their device right so
the models aprender the mo for these
guys is that they first find a list of
digital currency investors then they
figure out using length and Facebook etc
what is the phone number for those guys
then they basically go on and reset
Gmail Yahoo Mail etc etc because for all
email recovery you have to provide your
phone number you know as a backup
mechanism once they have access to your
email as well as phone number then it's
relatively easy to get in anywhere right
because we do things like device
verification so if you're logging into
point-based using a new device that we
will send you a challenge to your email
right so you can actually click a link
in the email if that tracker now has
control of the email and the attacker if
anyways not getting to Apatow concern
his phone so now the attacker is able to
essentially steal bitcoins right is that
clear I want to make sure that the the
premise is clear cool so so uh yeah
recently we've started recommending to
point with users that they should of
course use a strong password and a
password manager to store those
passwords and secondly you know they we
have been recommending them to move away
from anything SMS based over - you know
tott based apps like Google
Authenticator Microsoft Authenticator
etc why because like if you guys have
ever set up a TOTP you know using
Authenticator then you have to scan a QR
code at that time what is happening is
that the secret key with us which is
being shared between the website let's
say in this case coinbase and your
device and that is actually just being
shared by the virtue of you scanning you
know a QR code that's it so nothing gets
transmitted in the air and once that QR
code has been shared that both coinbase
and your phone are going to run the
exact email guards and using that secret
key we generate a six digit code so
that's why no one no one can convince a
call operator or you know otherwise
gain access to your Google Authenticator
based qtp right so yeah so so now even
though we've basically started telling
all our high-value users that hey you've
got to move away from SNS base to a PHA
to do TP not everybody does it right so
an order to ok policy still opt-in right
be a lot of people to still use SNS base
to efface and we still need to protect
them that's still actually the majority
of the users is right we still need to
protect those guys were still you
relying on SMS so now we try to use
machine learning to detect if a login
attempt is suspicious or not and thereby
if it's drol from the coinbase account
is suspicious or not and it's a very
hard problem to solve using machine
learning incredibly hard because in the
lifetime of the company there's only
being like handful of you know actual
account takeovers where we have followed
through and we can really say this was
not somebody just claiming that he was
hacked so he can get his money back
that was actually truly in accounting
over and therefore the data is highly
skewed and you haven't you haven't even
seen all varieties of you know account
takeovers such that we could even trade
a supervised machine learning algorithm
so therefore you know what we did was we
we try to you know use techniques like
techniques like Association rule mining
in order to discover new rules kind of
extrapolate even one example of a county
cover that you see and build a rule
around it and we starting with you know
a few rules and we gonna basically say
ok you know based on this rule it
appears that this log intercept is
suspicious and therefore we will delay
all the drawls from this account for the
next 48 hours right now the reason and
through the rest of this talk you know
I'm gonna I'm gonna bring a slaver about
you know various machine learning fit in
with you know non machine learning
systems and how can you design a
data-driven product right and of course
there's going to be false positives here
the false positives will be that you
know you're you for whatever reason we
detect
you're trying to send cryptocurrency
something we detect that you are an
attacker and that will be really
frustrating that will then mean that you
have to come back
like to us to our support and then you
know it's a very manual hand world
handheld process so what we've done is
we we've said that okay if there's a
false positive you have the option to
actually really prove who you are by
uploading your ID together with a selfie
together so you actually upload the
front at the back of your ID and you
take a picture of yourself holding the
ID so we can establish that you are in
possession of the ID and and we will
make sure that the name of the ID
matches the legal name on the account
right if you do that then we can
accelerate the delayed this withdrawal
that we delayed for 48 hours right cool
and of course if you are a victim of an
account takeover and somebody truly took
of took over your accountant is the
jointer principal your account then you
will receive an SMS and an email and you
can immediately go in to this view and
cancel the withdrawal or you could
actually a lock your account immediately
because for in that email there's a
there's a one-time URL which is tied to
your account which you can click you go
into a portal but you don't even have to
enter your password because it's a
one-time-only URL personalized for you
and you can immediately lock your
account and stay at peace that no one is
stealing your bitcoins at this point any
questions so far
okay so yeah so now I'm going to talk
about voting how do we detect fraud
right so so fraud prevention you know as
I said it's it's a hard-enough problem
that you can't do it using as a machine
learning or human intelligence alone so
our approach is that you gotta have both
of them working in cohesion and so
machine learning algorithms they train
so humans their labeling users as they
are reviewing them the they're doing
purchase patterns of users they create
they label them those labels then are
used by the machine learning algorithm
to learn a new model and then we present
a set of suspicious users to
our analysts who then take a look at
them and review them and say no this
purchase pattern looks sketchy this
doesn't look like you know this person
is truly the account holder and
therefore I'm going to ban the user I'm
going to reduce the limits of the user
so all those actions taken again in turn
by the humans they go in and train the
model again right so yeah so we use a
variety of supervised and unsupervised
machine learning algorithm we call it
internally Precog so there are two sets
of labels fraud and Knox rot so we train
a binary classifier using logistic
regression as I said earlier the collect
signals from users as they are browsing
to the site so we collect signals around
device fingerprint browser fingerprint
you know location of user emails phone
number etc etc from a lot of those data
sources like from email we try to find
out what are the other social media
profiles associated with it and we find
out the name and addresses behind those
social media profiles for likewise for
phone number we use data sources to find
out who is the fotomat adjuster too and
then again bring the name and address
behind it for ID we extract name and
address
SSN we look up label address and from
even the bank account we look up name
and address so you get the idea right so
we bring in names and addresses from all
these various sources right and the
output of the model is it's a logistic
regression model so we are actually
using the probability of being
fraudulent and mapping it to you know
you purchase limits right so now the
pressure is widened even machine
learning work here so the first reason
is as I described you're living
collecting email addresses from all
these different data sources and there's
lots of transforms that go in there to
decide you know whether the names and
addresses they mismatch across the data
sources right however you know why can't
we just have by couldn't we have just
use a simple rules based system the
reason being that you know even for real
users the names and addresses they
differ right across data sources like
Jonathan came at John King right or
people they move right and their
addresses are not update
in some data sources right so in real
world there's all these noisy effects
which make this a hard enough problem
that you can't dissolve using rule-based
system you have to use machine learning
so what we do so we have transforms like
Jaccard similarity where we would take
all the characters which are in common
between the two names right divided by
all the characters which are in the
Union set of the two names right the
second reason why machine learning works
to detect fraud is because of the broken
window theory
so this cameras they are constantly
talking amongst each other right they
discover this new loophole or this new
way of defrauding or using stolen credit
cards so they jump into a foreign talk
to each other and as our analysts are
you know observing these guys they are
banning them we are learning as well
right so for instance there was a time
when we saw the screen resolution 13 64
by 768 now the true probability of the
screen resolution occurring in reality
is less than 0.1% right because it's not
a real screen resolution at all the
scammers they were using Windows remote
desktop protocol to login to a remote
device and pretend to be coming in from
a different device fingerprint and
luckily windows RDP has a buzz via which
the the screen resolution is off by one
pixel on each side so we are really
thankful Microsoft for not fixing that
but please don't and so now our analysts
they discovered that you know there's a
there's a pattern and they started
banning more and more accounts right so
now you get the idea right our analysts
are banning accounts which are using
that screen resolution and then our
machine learning model which is trained
on a daily basis it picks up and it
extrapolated right yeah
in this case it was actually I'll come
to that in a minute it how we picked it
up we use anomaly detection to pick it
up yeah so how do we use the risk score
so so previously we used to you know
banned users who had a high risk score
but that would then mean that you know
if you were a false positives that is
you know we thought you were scammer but
the
you will really not then you had no
second chances you could not prove
yourself innocent right so then what we
did was we said okay we will allow even
the worst offenders even those who have
high high high risk scores to purchase
bitcoins from us at say let's say $5 of
bitcoins per day and that's almost like
then you know you're observing you and
it's almost like paying for training or
models right because we can then observe
you for let's say 60 day period and if
you see that you know you are truly
actually you know innocent then you know
the machine learning model will will
will collect itself right so yeah and
I'll go through a few more details about
our model so as I said largest
aggregation you know we of course you
know want to have the model be
generalizable because it would work much
better with respect to unseen data so
two ways of achieving generalizability
or reducing bias is basically first is
use regularization right so that is a
nice way of doing feature selection like
instead of somebody hand hand unique
features right you can just throw all
the the features there and let other as
one or l2 regularization figure out
which features are important and only
keep them in the model right secondly
you know use cross-validation to pick
the hyper parameter so you know like we
divide the the training set into chunks
of five five subsets train model on four
tests on the fifth and then do that five
times and then you figure out you know
out of all hyper parameters that you
could be using for the models which one
performs the best with respect to your
metric and then you pick that hyper
parameter you pick the best
regularization and you then train that
model on the entire training set right
now you know a nice intuitive way of
understanding how regularization helps
so if they are like so multicollinearity
or rather like having two features which
are like highly correlated with each
other can be bad for the model right so
regularization helps there because if
you use Elven regularization and two
features are highly highly correlated
hundred percent then l1 will pick just
one of them right and
make the other one zero l2 will
basically give both of them equal
coefficients right so our machine
learning pipeline a between our model
using valve Abbott I don't know how many
of you guys use warp alphabet in the
room too awesome yeah so love love Bob L
love it and it's an open source software
written by John Langford I think from
this time at Yahoo research and
Microsoft Research and the really nice
thing about Bob beloved is that ok it
can do it can learn a stochastic
gradient descent model you know online
using in a streaming fashion right and
other nice thing about it which you know
some which I think it's still relatively
unknown is that it has a demon mode so
how many of you guys have to be had to
deal with exporting the model using XML
like formats or if using Python then
pickling the model yeah cool so yeah so
when I started at coinbase about two
years ago I had a it was just me and an
intern so we were able to basically
build a model really really quickly
launch it really really quickly by not
worrying about you know exporting models
and PNNL and pickling etcetera etcetera
by just actually exploiting this this
thing involve a rabbit where you can run
it in daemon mode right so what we did
was we don't waffle rabbit and demon
lord and then we have a Python G event
you know green let's paste G events wrap
it around it and it works it works
really well flawlessly it never really
goes down you know skills very well and
now okay so the model training pipeline
so you know operation database is [ __ ]
production code bases in Ruby so we do
feature extraction using Python and then
we basically apply transforms using
Python as well and then we generate a
data set for bauble rabbit which trains
a model and then then we have to deploy
the model we just essentially copied
vocal mammoths vladats representation of
the model over to the server right and
then when you need to score a
we just send the feature vector you know
from our production database to the
server it's actually because we wanted
to launch very very fast we designed it
to be stateless so on the scoring side
there is no state all state when we want
even score a user is being generated
using the production code base right
which has its own set of issues and now
we talk about them so first of all let
me talk a little bit about metrics so
you know for logistic regression you
know it's a binary classifier so you
could have two metrics like area under
the curve which will allow you to know
how well is the model performing with
respect to separating out good users and
bad users right however if you remember
we are no longer banning people right so
even for our business use case it
doesn't match and this is something
which you know unfortunately textbooks
or schools don't really teach right like
how do you map machine learning metrics
to the business metrics right so a
various Loblaws which is essentially you
know how close is the probability of
being straw Geling you know how close is
that value to one for fraudsters and how
close is that value to zero for good
guys right that map's very well to our
use case right because if you recall
what we're doing is we're taking your
probability of being fraudulent and
giving you a purchase power it is it
based on that right and then the
business metric is fraud rate so we
measure how much losses we took from
chargebacks right from all the Alice's
in the world calling up the banks that's
the numerator the denominator is the
purchase volume right and you know this
is a period of more than a year or a
year rather so you can see the goal um
we started as at a young when we started
this about two years ago it was actually
much higher than that and we've been
consistently able to keep it below now
except a few months here and there now I
wanted to talk a little bit about you
know if but I told you about you know
how we are describing this current
thereby limits to people people treat
the the purchase limits on
very religiously it's it's almost to
them like a credit limit on a credit
card right and the so if you can imagine
I don't I don't have a slice of this as
we are learning more and more about a
user right you know you do more
purchases we've you purchase patterns
right stammers typically if they have
access to a bank account you know the
two kinds of patterns they will you know
let's say we give them a ten thousand
dollar a week limit you know the greedy
ones they will steal ten thousand
dollars every week the more
sophisticated ones will try to add some
randomness over there right so so yeah
so so therefore a machine learning model
it is actually observing everything that
you're doing and we keep recoding you as
you do and more and more things on our
platform and therefore as you're doing
more things on the platform we learn a
new score your purchase power changes
right but you can't change it too often
either if you change it too often then
this is what happens if there's a bug
introduced to norm in our model then we
have a very loyal
you know customer base they get onto
reddit or they write to support and then
they freak out then my limits are going
crazy if what happened to them
this is actually you know you know
something we fixed the rapture by
essentially saying that okay we're not
going to score or Reese who uses all the
time we will score them you know only a
certain you know lifetime intervals etc
that's one way the other way at this
time what had happened was that we had
deployed the model and there was an
error and that's what I wanted to talk a
little bit about how do you actually
validate models right and how do you
validate that your model is going to do
what you expect it to do because you
know if you go wrong if you make mistake
that's that's a support nightmare right
so yeah so as I said BR we have two
different code bases for one for
training and one for you know scoring
right feature engineering as well as
transforms as well as the data bases
underlying data bases they are totally
different so that now means that you
know when we are training a model right
between the model you're using above it
and if the models metrics are
really good compared to the production
model that we had trained and deployed
of let's say a few weeks earlier then we
want to not deploy this Challenger model
into production but you can't just do
that because as I said you know if you
deploy it now you know because we
trained it using you know PI using
Python and redshift in our case based
environment and if you deploy it then
the scoring is going to be done using
Ruby and MongoDB environment so we can't
just do that yeah so what we have to do
is you know you first take a set of
users right and you compute the same
feature vector you know using both the
code bases and then you essentially you
know you run an algorithm which compares
the feature vectors and figures are
there too many discrepancies and you
also figure out are there too many
discrepancies in the scores right and
you know this is also very it's a little
hard problem because you know databases
are not going to be always like you know
in sync either right there is an ETL
process for instance which is moving
data from one data from a production
database to our you know from a
production MongoDB database to a
redshift database right and at the same
time users are doing stuff right so they
may have purchased more stuff by the
time we actually did given this the sort
of validation of verification right
so therefore yeah you can't always get
that validation right you have to
essentially look at okay did the other
scores you can't really solve the
problem that other schools exactly the
same using the two code bases but you
can say are they not differing too much
and then you plot the histograms of the
differences and then you know if it if
it's not too much of deviations then you
go ahead with it the second thing you
have to do is that you know the second
thing we do is that we then deploy the
challenge of model in production now
this is a problem or the problem here is
between the model using logistic
regression which internally is using log
loss to decide the best model right but
we don't know if that machine learning
metric corresponds to a business metric
right of fraud rate so therefore what we
do is we deploy the Challenger model in
our mode we score the user using
Baltimore's production and Challenger
but we assign limits or you know
purchase power only using the production
model and then the you know compute the
distribution for a set of samples for
good uses on the left and bad uses on
the right and if it doesn't look too bad
then we actually go ahead with moving
the Challenger model to be the
production model
one of the other things we have to do
and we have to be really really careful
about it is that there's high value
users on our platform who may have I
think highest purchase limit on our
platform right now is $15,000 a week
right and you don't want to mess with
that right so what we do is then we take
a set of decaying actually all the high
value users and we see what are their
scores with the Challenger model and
thereby compute how much is the purchase
power going to be after this new model
is deployed there will be false
positives right and we have you have to
learn to live with false positives if
you model you know in the long run in
the with respect to the log loss metric
is actually accurate then you might as
well accept the false positive but what
you have to do is then you take all
those users or the the whales whose
scores will go lower whose purchase
power will go lower and then you
manually go in and increase the limit or
lock the limits right so that once you
deploy the new model nothing
nothing bad happens to them cool so now
yeah so so as I said you know like in a
startup world you have to be expedient
pragmatic etc so you know we we got a
new model going in a three month time
span using two of us and now as the team
drew we realized that you know we can
actually do much better right we can
actually basically not have not have
these two code bases so this is our new
architecture which you're working
towards and what you want to achieve is
you know for all the data that we are
interested in with respect to training
amoral we will actually send all of that
data you know from a production database
to you know
I have DynamoDB over there to another to
other micro-service which has its own
data store right and then we will have
to ensure that the this microservice
data store is actually in sync and it's
not lagging too much to behind the
parasha database that's one metric we'll
have to make sure we hit and then we
will have the same library which
extracts signals and thus transforms
right and now then you need to get get a
score right or sorry when you have to
train a bottle then you basically just
use use this data store right the
DynamoDB data store between the model
and then you need to get a score you
basically hit a user ID right and you
take the the signals and the transform
feature vector and then you get a score
using that same data store right so
that's that's what we are driving
towards now I wanted to give you a
flavor of where does you know supervised
machine learning fail so the first thing
is the charge back window is is very
large right so you can't really rely on
getting a label that the user is
fraudulent after 60 days right or 6
months they've gotta use unsupervised
approaches in or extrapolate human
intuition so there's three of them the
first one as I mentioned is anomaly
detection so what we do is we basically
take a look at okay how many people are
signing up with Wells Fargo Bank issued
credit cards on a monthly basis and in
any given week if that number the red
line is the weekly ratio in any given
week if the number of user signing up
using Wells Fargo exceeds and we know
there's something wrong then we quickly
go and look at all those users who
signed up that week and find out what's
wrong and that's how we found that that
screen resolution ring then the second
one is related users detection so if you
ban a user right then you know like if
two accounts they share the same social
security number or same bank account
number then they are controlled by the
same individual so if we know that this
icon was created by a fraudster then
very likely the others were created by
the fraudster as well so we have a you
know I'd attend a deterministic way by
which we can
linked accounts we also have a
probabilistic way the probabilistic one
basically just takes the feature vectors
of all the accounts and computes the
cosine similarity between them and if
they are very similar
then once an admin and analyst banned an
account we present all other related
accounts that they can act on the third
thing is you know we built a custom
rules engine so our analysts as they are
looking at you know accounts and finding
these rings they're like they're
discovering you know okay there's a
JPMorgan Chase Bank issued ring you know
all of them are using let's say Verizon
phone numbers and then they say okay
let's actually district the just go to
this value right now some of the actions
we allow the the risk engine or the
rules engine you take is okay you can
add a band a user you can restrict the
restore or we can require an ID upload
right and what we're working towards the
you know automatically discovering rules
right so that would be like the holy
grail here right if you can actually
have anomaly detection detect rules and
then you input those rules and then you
can remove a lot of them the human
intervention out of the picture I'll
give you a one case study here which we
call the Verizon debit card ring so
these are actually fake IDs they have
just different driver license numbers
right and they were photoshopped right
and we call it the Verizon ring because
as I said earlier you know it's very
easy to actually start seeing smsql fake
codes you know on online previously
views to think that in order to create
an account on coinbase its high enough
friction for you for scammers that they
have to purchase a phone and then five
verify a phone it's actually easy right
there's temporary websites where you can
actually get smsql fake codes online
right and also verizon has this major
loophole if any of you have drivers
phones come talk to me after this
Verizon has a major loophole they're you
know if I as a hacker have access to
username and password for Verizon I can
see all text messages you receive
including through a fake codes right so
therefore if I'm a scammer that's the
best phone number that's the best
username password of any carrier to
purchase
so I would go look at you know password
leaks of Verizon phones and lo and
behold I can now you know use a quite a
verizon phone number to validate
coinbase account and the person whose
verizon phone number is being used he's
not even aware that his phone number is
being used to verify a coin based
account okay yep so we detected this
ring you know as I said using actually
in this case as well using anomaly
detection because cameras we always
leave you know they always leave
something wanting they always make one
mistake so in this case they use the
same screen resolution right so anomaly
detection is picked it up and then we
basically you know as the user was
adding more and more cards you know and
we had already seen that card being used
on other band accounts then we
immediately use machine learning to
figure it out that this was this new
account is of scammer as well and
therefore we reduce the risk reduce the
purchase power of that user so on and
all you know with some human
intervention both supervised and
unsupervised approaches they helped us
in this case and don't really have much
time but you know I thought I will share
with you some interesting IDs so for
instance V when I said the require users
to upload an ID right and as I told you
earlier that you know you have to also
do your you know selfie together with
your ID this is this is the stuff be
gotten yesterday really no wise but yeah
so that's my email address subsequent
viscom
you know this is the team 15 people now
so seven analysts and eight engineers
who wear a variety of hats you know data
engineers machine learning engineers
front-end and back-end engineers and we
are hiring for all the rules and if you
remember anything from the stock then
SMS to factor is dead
thank you
[Applause]